hallo mein name ist willkommen ihr fragt
euch bestimmt so hier keiner ist das
liegt
ich meine die sind gerade auf
klassenfahrt oder so jedenfalls ist eine
person hier geblieben und zwar so
connelly
er deswegen haben wir beides heute
gedacht dass wir zusammen ein video
aufnehmen was auch für sie stimmt männer
wie gesagt nicht deswegen sind wir
einfach wieder auf die website texte die
ich gegangen wie ich damals man deckt
hat wo man so ein paar tests machen kann
ja da gibt es auf jeden fall dieses quiz
wie gut kennst du caux lilly & co
scheiße jetzt sind natürlich balu oder
offizielle auf klassenfahrt
schaut man gerade durch die tür rein
gekommen
dietrich am start und mehr hammer hallo
den kunden
wir werden jetzt mal die einzelnen
fragen hier beantworten und kollege
bekam ihren namen und ihr gesicht in
einem video in dem luca den akinator
fragte
ich habe keine ich glaube nicht ich
klicke mal auf falschen kolonie ist eine
unglückliche kollege gesagt dass dann
kannst du dir dass du dich du bist alles
klar ich klicke trotzdem einfach auf war
weil ich glaube dass für mich schon
innerlich magst
freunde also ich dachte echt dass hier
in kurz kommen wir zu wirklich relevante
fragen sowie viele seiten hatten kollege
oder wie groß sind die augen oder so
aber dann kommt
das ist eine super frage definitiv war
das stimmt ich weiß dass die mich lieber
louis der hund aus nintendogs da müssen
wir fragen einige leute bemängeln ja
dass sich 80 euro für diesen push und
ausgegeben habe aber
guckt ihn euch an
können diese augen lügen
wieso lügen
können diese augen nicht so sein nein es
geht was im auge aber nun ist der hund
aus nintendogs balu ist ein
zwergpinscher well dem schild nee du
bist ein shiba inu also falsch alu ist
frech
in serie aber wahr
um welche bei jukic und jetzt sage ich
gerade falls sie eventuell gar nicht
kennen verlinkt ich euch hier oben einem
händler zufolge die könnt ihr euch
anschauen wenn ihr euch babalu wer das
überhaupt ist wie findet ihr das
eigentlich wenn ich manchmal so ab und
zu videos verlinkte die mit dem jetzigen
video irgendwie in bezug stehen das
mache ich ja wirklich nur dann wenn die
videos mit jetzigen videos in bezug
steht finde das hat eigentlich ganz gut
weil dadurch kann ich sagen hey park in
palo nicht kenntlich her wenn ich da bin
ich wie so ein bösewicht der seine katze
irgendwie wir machen wir damit den kurs
wie soll ich denn weitermachen mit dem
quiz welcher balu ist denn gemeint ich
sag mal einfach das balu frech ist die
nächste frage handelt von vital park
eine suite trinken wasser
versteht ihr baby
falls irgendjemand von meinen zuschauern
eventuell erzieherin in der
krabbelgruppe tempel den kleinen babys
doch mal meine videos weil ich dort auf
dem niveau sind wir gut angekommen auch
ja wie terror ist männlich vitello ist
in einem akinator video entstanden
immer wenn ich auf mein tisch lage denn
ich der bricht zusammen als ob die
ganzen figuren akinator videos
entstanden sind
doch ist er wirklich ne
ich hab dich in die hand genommen wollte
ich suchen versuchen
gut übrigens gibt es schon so krasse
fanseiten von vitello und willi und balu
und du warum gehen diese gang so ab das
ist hier überlegen dass ich für so eine
scheiße wirklich geradeaus denke einfach
so wenn ich so mache die musik verbinden
ich muss ja arbeiten die welt schon
wieder an
ca
heimat geklingelt das heißt einerseits
meine pizza im ofen fertig und
andererseits die bayern gegen wolfsburg
weiter
egal wir spielen noch weiter noch koch
die nächste frage handelt von vitello
balu und kolonie
wie soll ich das denn jetzt machen ich
muss gerade die maus mit meiner linken
ansteuern
das klappt gerade erhielt super ja die
sind alle beim akinator zu finden dann
klicke ich mal auf auswertung und sie
haben acht von zehn
was habe ich getan bekennt die gegen
luca schon ganz gut mit ein bisschen
übung macht für demnächst alles richtig
ich kenne die ganz gut
ich sitze gerade zusammen mit den allen
auf dem stuhl da meine pizza fertig ist
nicht kein bock auf seine schwarze
zahlen
coli vielfalt
sechs männer heraus late trad seit
sechseinhalb stunden auf die 1
und die welle einfach nicht kommen
coletti es ist nicht schlimm
jeder war mal verletzt und jeder hat man
irgendwie verband getragen
du brauchst dich da nicht schämen und
jetzt einfach hierhin vor die kamera
sagt den leuten noch einmal schön
tschüss am ende des videos und dann
kriegst haben doch keine teuren
kartoffeln okay okay
es ist hübsch coli kann euch doch ziehen
oder stimmt natürlich die beiden
verabschieden euch ich jetzt meine pizza
aus und ich mache jetzt meine kartoffeln
und dann hoffen wir mal dass das ich
sollte vielleicht keinen arzt werden wir
hoffen dass das video ist gefallen getan
haben wir uns über den bewertungen
freuen schreibt man alle gute besserung
in die kommentare weil dann heilt
kollege schneller ein like gleich ein
bestens